[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whenever there's a story about
tv tv sport andrew marshawn is the guy
the new york post senior sports media
columnist he's been killing it here in
the offseason and uh andrew joins us now
andrew where do we stand with troy
aikman has he
what's holding up him going to espn to
do monday night football
if that's going to happen he's going to
go for five years and 90 plus million
dollars
which is pretty good we'll take him
through abc slash espn super bowl
the average salary will be more than the
deal tony romo got a few years ago that
was 10 years and 180 million dollars
from cbs so it's just not official yet
there's some paperwork uh that has to be
done
and we're waiting for other shoes to
drop so if they make an announcement
they
may
wait and try to make a double
announcement because if you're going to
spend that money on troy aikman
and this is no offense to steve levy but
you're not going to have steve levy
paired with troy aikman it or are you is
that still a possibility are they they
looking at making a big splash without
michaels or joe buck
so yeah this is the list for them the
first they're gonna see if fox will
allow them to talk to joe buck who was
one year left on his contract he makes
11 million dollars to be the number one
play-by-player uh for the nfl and
baseball for fox uh and so
that's their number one they aikemin and
buck are are close uh they've been
together for two decades now i could see
that happening if it doesn't they'll
look at al michaels they like al
michaels al michaels is you know late
70s
the question for them is does he get you
to that super bowl in february 2027 do
you
kind of pushing
the bigger issue off for a while uh
internally chris fowler's their national
championship caller
they like him uh to me he's not as
strong
as these other guys and then the other
wild card would be iron eagle
from cbs i was the number two on the nfl
for them
who has a contract but
i think they would try to
possibly finagle him out of his deal
well so what's amazon doing on thursday
night
so they've
al michael's nbc and now michael's um
bit of do basically after the super bowl
so how michael's is their number one
choice uh it's a three-year deal i think
30 plus million dollars is what's on the
table um and
uh
al has been kind of 90 but he's been
waiting to see
who the analyst is going to be
first wanted chris collins to come with
them collinsworth doesn't want to do two
games
then one at aikman aikman was close to
signing with amazon where he possibly
could have split his time between amazon
who will have exclusive rights to
thursday night football come this fall
which is a big milestone for tv just
going straight for nfl tv going straight
to streaming uh
and then after that he really he has a
close relationship with sean mcvay the
dinner together with their wives and
mcveigh's fiance uh owling his one wife
i should say wife um and so i
don't want to start any rumors uh so
they're they're they have a relationship
obviously for amazon al michaels
probably the greatest play by player of
all time super bowl winning coach uh
that would have been pretty good uh but
that's not happening mcveigh is staying
uh and so did mcvay get an offer andrew
so it never got to that i mean the rams
knew that that was out there that he
could have they amazon
from what i know would have gone to five
years 100 million dollars that range now
you know he's going to talk i think
later today he might say oh there was it
was there i mean i could get into all
the how everything works you know the
inside of it but uh
mcveigh there was real interest mcveigh
espn went after mcveigh two years ago
tried to get him for monday night um
after the whitten booger uh
arrangement didn't work in terms of
analysts um
and
you listen to mcveigh i mean you know
you can only go by so much people say he
has an interest in doing this um the
rams
i'd be surprised if you know within five
years mcvay's not a broadcaster if you
look at
what he said he wants us he's getting
he's getting married he doesn't want to
be a football lifer um but this rams
team has a chance to win again he has
the quarterback but then he leaves um
then he can decide to come back to
coaching like i was joking daniel like
this is that i wanted him originally to
sign with espn so then i could start
writing about how he's leaving espn
coach
uh mcveigh is somebody on there now kirk
herb street is someone who's high on
amazon's list
all right if al michaels goes to amazon
you think he'll be paired with who
so herb street i right now i would say
is someone um who i would most likely um
to me is a very good choice right you're
picking a broadcaster not a quarterback
so the fact that herb street never
played the nfl i think
you know what kind of analyst you're
going to get and when you're amazon
you're starting this new service
streaming people have to find it you
know that's why they want al michaels
they want it to feel big they want it to
feel familiar um
and i think al at this point he's still
great throws
um not 95 97 in his prime but 1992 still
very good herth street's a perfect
compliment for him you know does al like
that you know al likes the stars madden
uh collinsworth aikman mcveigh those
type of people herb shoots a star in
college not in the nfl so will al be
totally pleased with that uh i don't
know the wild card
joe buck goes the espn suddenly fox has
an opening to do the super bowl two of
the next three years al michaels has
done 12 greatest ever yes um a little
bit older but i look i'm not saying fox
would do that i think more likely kevin
burkhart moves up um
very you know he was excellent ready to
do it in my opinion great guy um and
deserves it
but
do you say look we just lost joe buck
and troy aikman al michaels is out there
we get him to do two of the next three
super bowls um and kind of i kind of
wrote michael's did the uh tom brady
thing this past super bowl great
performance you know kind of put that
stamp on if again it's a silly argument
which is what i cover uh who the
greatest play-by-play of player is of
all time at 78 to have the game he had
um but now you go off and get two more
super bowls and you know summer all did
12. al's done 12 he gets the 14 in terms
of super bowl uh that's a pretty good
exclamation point on a career what are
the mannings paid for the manning cast
so
nobody is
i know i've heard numbers not confirmed
but yeah look they're in that
neighborhood of where romo and aikman is
the espn the way that they're able to
somewhat pay these people
is that they make it a digital deal now
obviously disney overall is making espn
plus um a priority so that budget is
bigger um so peyton does peyton's places
he has omaha productions so that money
is kind of goes through there and and
those are real things i mean they've
been successful payton's places have
been successful for espn plus i mean you
know success is defined you know
different ways but people do like uh
payton on those shows and um from what
i'm told in terms of what they see
internally in terms of those streams but
yes he's in that range he's making a lot
of money uh to to do the 10 man and cast
from home uh it's a pretty good deal for
both sides though it was it was
excellent for espn as well you know and
that's why it was kind of a little bit
like oh well they have the manning cast
you know do they need aikman yeah but
they're looking towards that super bowl
yeah and i wondered about that too that
troy is going to miss out on a couple of
super bowls with fox where he's going to
get one super bowl with the mothership
it looks like but then you have the
manning cast
and plus when you work on monday night
football you don't just work on monday
night football you get put through the
car wash there he's going to be on get
up he's going to be on you know radio
shows you know van pelt show like that
goes along with the territory i agree
with you dan most likely but i will say
like when romo was talking to espn and i
was so ready to write the romo rules i
couldn't wait to write it uh if he had
gone to espn i don't think roma would
have been doing everything like i think
he would have done the games and i i
agree with you you know better than i do
the espn culture is you do all these
things and maybe troy will end up doing
that i don't know if that's in his deal
that no i don't have to do all this
other stuff i just want to do the games
like i did at fox um
but yes if he does it's a different
animal um and also that broadcast is
more scrutinized now the manicast takes
a little bit of the pressure off the
main broadcast because people can go to
that if they're not if they're not as
interested in the game but you know
sunday afternoon on fox and cbs is the
best window first off it's the most
viewed those games are watched by more
than any other
window and secondly everyone is doing a
lot of different things on sunday
there's more than one game
you get to watch your team on sunday
generally speaking there's fantasy
that's even more active than it is on
monday so the focus isn't as much on you
uh the broadcast team on monday night
get a lot of bad you know you get some
bad games focus is on the broadcast crew
and that in the defense of the steve
levies and the greasies the riddicks etc
that is harder
they've gotten they have a harder task
than these other teams and when they're
compared that's sometimes kind of unfair
romo changed all of this didn't he
yes so and look from cbs's point of view
the reason they the people are probably
listening why would you give tony romo
10 years 180 million dollars the reason
they did that is because the nfl
broadcast deals were all up cbs nbc espn
turned down amazon got involved fox and
so espn wanted to get tony romo with the
thought that that would help them get
super bowls and get these larger deals
because if you look at what the most
important um
property in sports in television overall
85 of the top 100 shows are the nfl so
the reason they did that they wanted
romo on their side um could they have
gotten them cheaper if they you know
negotiate a little bit differently
probably but it didn't happen that way
it worked out i could go through 100
different things that worked out for
romo and he ended up with that crazy
contract 10 years 180 million dollars
and then you have the ripple effect of
course aikman sees that you know he was
making
around seven million you know in that
range at that point um and and he's like
i'm the you know i'm a better
quarterback hall of famer and i've been
doing this for 20 years as a number one
why am i not paid that much and now he
is
yeah
you just um
do they really matter
when i
am i going to stay am i going to tune
into a game because tony romo is doing
it
uh am i going to tune in for troy aikman
am i tuning in for how michael is there
like how do these networks uh evaluate
this that
this is worth it you're going to stay
with me longer i mean how many of those
broadcasters do we really tune in
because they're doing the games andrew
100
you know like what you do
for the audience you're the attraction
so whatever you get paid you're
listening to the dan patrick show and
the danettes and that's the show and
obviously you know the money you know
can be similar to what this money is um
you know you could tell what you make if
you want dan um the uh but the uh but
when you look at the games uh yeah these
people do not make the ratings change
what they do do though there is a star
power to it it does feel bigger
and that's important and the bigger
thing is it's important to the league
the league wants these boots to be feel
like number one booths
but i will say this like before the
romos contract they just mentioned why
they did it i was told by nfl brand it
doesn't really matter to us you know at
the end of the day they're gonna take
the what the highest bids are um for
these contracts and then in terms of
watching
you don't like so when you look at fox's
decision with like kevin burkhart and
greg olsen let's just say joe buck
leaves they just have to really feel
confident that come super bowl sunday
next year they're going to be able to do
a good enough job that the focus isn't
on them you know it's great if they do
amazing job and everyone thinks they're
awesome and they get great reviews but
you can't you can't have it where
that the focus is for whatever reason on
your broadcast booth instead of the game
that would be you know just pr wise is
it does it go dollars and cents does it
matter no i mean the money night
football ratings were up last year uh so
do they really need troikman to make
them go even higher no but they want
that marquee
and especially when you're still
negotiating maybe for sunday ticket with
the nfl uh amazon's about to make their
booth uh it didn't happen of course you
know al michael still might happen but
al and troy uh and then you come in you
say no we'll get troy not only that
we're gonna get joe buck uh maybe uh
then
that that could that does probably help
you a little bit
who is the sports media mvp
well i mean look what you like i'm not
like kissing buddy here on national uh
tv but i think with you mcafee colin
coward chris russo stephen a skip
bayless
i'm not saying you're the mvp but in
terms of value right you're doing an
entertainment value the talk show host
or or the big time podcast that big cat
and uh
pmt
pft com commenter um
that type of person you know that's the
show so
you could argue that again i guess who's
worth the most
those people are probably worth the most
because there's no dan patrick show
without dan patrick there is a game
without um
without the game so i guess
so i mean look you you asked me this is
kind of i'd say mcafee right now right
like he is the one who
is
not you know you you did this kind of
you left um espn and
started your own thing but now mcafee's
doing it where it's just youtube so just
the pipes um he's on sirius xm but he um
but so so he's creating his own everyone
else kind of has an attachment like even
steven a um he's very important to espn
but stephen a leaves tomorrow espn i
don't know do they make less money maybe
i mean first take makes some money um
and steven a is important and can you
replace steven a you probably
can replace steven a but with who and
how confident are you that you're gonna
get the same ratings and make as much
money with that show so i would say the
talk show host type is the the
opinionator is uh opinionists are the uh
the ones who probably the most valuable
thank you andrew we'll be uh we'll be
watching we'll be reading
great thanks man that's andrew marchand
he's the new york post senior sports
media columnist also co-host of marshawn
and orand the sports media podcast